many parents as gail mentioned at the
top are still waiting to hear about
their children but at the same time some
names of victims are starting to emerge
and lilia luciano is outside a hospital
here
getting the latest lilia it's been a
very traumatic night for so many good
morning to you
good morning tony and imagine this to
pile on to the trauma some of those
parents had to give dna samples to
identify the children that were killed
i'll tell you about uvalde we're about
60 miles away from the u.s mexico border
this is a predominantly latino community
and as we all know one thing that we all
have in common in our latino communities
is that family is everything and that
family goes beyond blood ties to include
neighbors and friends so the impact of
this tragedy is truly exponential
parents gathered at uvalde civic center
late into the night tuesday to await
word on their children's fate
a volunteer we spoke with took these
images as parents worked with
authorities to gather dna samples to
help them identify the victims the scene
was pretty horrific and
i understand that some of the
bodies were hard to
to recognize among the confirmed victims
nine-year-old emery joe garza
her father posted this photo to facebook
with a single word comment why annabel
guadalupe rodriguez was just 10 years
old shortly after the shooting her
father's desperation was clear as he
arrived at the school grounds
i got to find her after shooting it
they don't know where she's at eva
mireles taught fourth grade at robb
elementary school
trained in bilingual and special
education
on the school's website she wrote that
she had a supportive fun and loving
family her husband ruben ruiz is an
officer of the uvalde police force
officials say the gunman went from
classroom to classroom shooting
indiscriminately as parents spoke with
authorities the horror of what happened
to their children became clear there
were some families that were upset and
raising their voices some of the law
enforcement officials where they would
be given the information as far as a
confirmation of death and then the
families would break down you imagine
the worst of the worst that could ever
happen to a parent
rob elementary has almost 600 students
between second third and fourth grade
most of them latino some of those
students are recovering in this hospital
here we know that tomorrow was supposed
to be the last day of school but of
course classes and all activities were
canceled yesterday until further notice
and according to the district there will
be grief counselors available to those
in need tony
lilia thank you very much
nate michelle gail as i send it back to
you guys in new york i want to linger on
that last note from lilia summer
vacation was due to start here tomorrow
yeah i'm struck by that too yeah one
more day two more days of school two
more days the rest of their lives
changed tony we appreciate you we'll
check back in with you in a little bit